اليوم هو يوم مهم وحاسم في تاريخ الكره
العربيه كل الاعين متجهه الى استاد
الثمامه غرب الدوحه الملعب الذي ستقام على
ارضه المباراه بين المنتخب المغربي
والمنتخب البرتغالي للتاهل الى النصف
النهائي هذه المره المغرب اول منتخب عربي
يصل الى الدور ربع النهائي بتاريخ كاس
العالم والمغرب كذلك اول منتخب عربي لم
يخسر خلال مبارياته الاربعه بتاريخ العالم
بتاريخ كاس العالم عفوا والمغرب مره اخرى
تواجه البرتغال اليوم للمره الثالثه في
تاريخ كاس العالم
1986 فازت المغرب ثلاثه واحد همم على همم
في المباريات وال 2018 فازت على برازيل
اوروبا البرتغال واحد صفر ولقاء المغرب
والبرتغال هو بحد ذاته مباراه بين اقوى
هجوم واقوى دفاع في نسخه قطر هذا العام
هذا
المونديال يعني البرتغال تملك 12 هدفا
بعدما سجلت ثلاث اهداف على غانا بهدف وهدف
كذلك على كوريا الجنوبيه وبهد على
الاوروغواي وسته اهداف على سويسرا اما
المغرب فلم تتلقى الا هدفا واحدا خلال
البطوله من كندا طبعا وكان هدف عكسي للاسف
يعني هذا اذا شاهدنا الجماهير هون بتشوف
كثير من وصلوا الى المغرب بتوقع حضرتك من
مراكز
حضرتك
مع اسبانيا المنتخب المغربي
ديالنا رفع الراس الرايه المغربيه
والامه العربيه والاسلاميه وان شاء الله
واحد صفر للمغرب طبعا
الكاميرا باللون الاحمر
يقوي سوف
الركراكي دير النيه وما تخافش غالبين
غالبين ان شاء الله
وانت كمان من المغرب
ههه
[تصفيق]
شكرا
[موسيقى]
من عمان ايه
اليوم مغربي كله مغربي شو رايك بالمنتخب
المغرب